you mentioned suffering that there is a
connection between consciousness and
suffering
that suffering is a fundamental part
the capacity to suffer is the
fundamental part of being human i mean
look at when you're not conscious you
don't suffer you know we've had
operations where we've been put under
anesthetic we're not conscious and we
don't suffer during the operation if we
were conscious we would
um
but there's also i mean there's a
non-physical suffering that is very much
tied to consciousness i can
think of things right now that will
cause me suffering like pain that i've
caused or pain that other people i care
about have felt or so on
so i don't see how
um
i think that way i think it's equally
true of joy joy is also a product of
consciousness
all tied in in some beautiful messy way
with memory and so on
that we can re-experience it when we
recall the memories
um but why is there suffering you
mentioned evil why is there evil in the
world you can
uh tell stories about this why is there
suffering why is there evil in the world
um if there's a god that cares so
let's assume for a minute that every
everything was a primitive robot
it would there would be no suffering but
there would also be no growth
and
and that implies choices like i
one of the things that i that i've said
that that
i know
i know why it hurts people and i don't
mean it quite the way that
but i will say it nonetheless is
the holocaust presents
the exact same theological question
as somebody who gets shot on the streets
of a city in los angeles which is god
why do you allow some people to do bad
things to other people
it's on an unimaginable scale but it's
the same question and the answer has to
be
you either allow people that free will
or you don't you can't say as god i'm
gonna have let everybody have free will
but not nazis
nazis don't get free will um because
cambodians
they can kill each other rwandans kill
each other but but the nazis don't get
to do that
so
that's one part piece of of the puzzle
um
and and what makes it unfathomable is
when you're actually faced with
suffering these kinds of explanations
are obscene they just are you can't i
mean when somebody is actually suffering
oh the rabbi said god gave people free
will that's just awful
but there is a second piece to this also
which is
that there is
natural suffering
like children born with diseases or
earthquakes or volcanoes or whatever um
and
and here my argument is that in some
ways suffering has to be random in the
world because
when people say why do bad things happen
to good people well if only good things
happen to good people everybody would be
good
but it would it would have no moral
content the only way you can be good and
have moral content is say i know that i
can live a really good life and have
really terrible things happen to me
nonetheless
so
it feels to me like it has to be a
randomly now that means by the way
that
i've been incredibly lucky i don't have
a good life because i was good
i have a good life because i was lucky
and that implies not that i should feel
guilty about it but that i have a
tremendous responsibility as a result to
other people who aren't so lucky
tremendous responsibility to study the
lessons of history to tell the stories
of those who are less lucky
and to
draw enough wisdom from them so that we
have less cruelty and suffering in the
world or have new kinds
that get us to improve even more that's
right exactly that we suffer better
you